ready get directly centered I'm ready to
fill hey reject nation Greg Alva here
Stacey Stacey Oh Howard on Instagram and
Twitter followed her there miss movies
every Wednesday live on the youtubes we
are gonna talk about our top 5 favorite
films to watch on this lovely holiday
Valentine's Day Stacey will be out of
town with her be at her buff mustache
now bf still have that he's got yeah
everything everything let me go no
matter how much harder you push for it
and I will be in my apartment with my
girlfriend on Valentine's Day
anyway guys let's hop into this list
shall we all right Stacey why don't you
kick it off from 5 through 1 number 5
number 5 so these are movies that you
can watch on Valentine's Day I should
preface this by saying that not every
couple likes rom-coms or like
lovey-dovey movies so if you want to
watch a movie together these are good
options to do Valentine's Day oh but
number 5 this is gonna be an indie film
it's called the Eagle versus shark if
you guys haven't heard of it take it
with teetee who of course
directed a bunch of amazing smaller
films before he did this gigantic
juggernaut that is marvel it's super
cute it stars and Jemaine Clement RV st.
Germain Clemente from Flight of the
Conchords from Planet Ramones yes and
also you know and what we do the shadows
and all that fantastic stuff so it's
quirky and cute and really sweet and
it's just a good little watch so eagle
versus shark is on Netflix check it out
that's my number 5 what a feeling your
picks are gonna be a lot more
interesting than my cliche picks to go
from I'm a basic [ __ ] sometimes I went
with these movies that I thought would
be good for couples to watch a single
people don't watch romantic movies on
No No so I went with ones that actually
move me especially by the end of the
film and it all comes to fruition so my
number five pick is from the legendary
comedian who everyone still loves Adam
Sandler one of his awesome rom-com 50
first dates yes there's some spoilers in
this video so while the ending of this
movie is ridiculous with this woman who
just relives the same day over and over
again and then by the end of the film
they're married and they have a kid he
has to constantly update this one VHS
baby
constantly it's a constant update he's
always making so he can keep having the
time of his life with her it's confusing
yeah it's it's ridiculous that's why
it's number five on my list however
whenever I get to that damn ending
there's something about it that brings
me to tears
the ending of when he's on the boat and
then DC they got married in there yeah
because it's like this guy she's willing
to do anything for the woman he loves
and he will just every single day to
keeping her updated so she can always
remember or be yeah I don't know what
the word is remember but be updated on
what their life is that yeah sure it
moves me to tears man I think of this
movie as a horrifying thought okay if
they had a kid right imagine waking up
you think you're gonna be in your own
bed you think you're gonna be living
your life and go paint and pick a
pineapple and you have your day off it's
a nice Sunday and you have like a
[ __ ] pregnancy belly and you're like
what I cannot think of a more horrifying
thing well then you can write and direct
the realistic take on 50 every day you
wake up and you're like what the [ __ ]
this guy's pregnant movie it's with
Colin Firth and Nicole Kidman and Mark
Strong maybe it's that it's 50 first
dates but it's a horror movie really
because she wakes up all the time and
it's like I don't know my life I don't
know who you are I don't know what's
happening
and yeah I think it's like before I go -
don't leave don't don't ruin my movie
okay don't ruin my choice this isn't a
discussion it's only the worst case
scenario I can ever think yeah let's
move on to number four Stacy number four
oh this one's interesting now I like
adventures you know I like sci-fi so I
went with the cute little film called
Stardust oh good choice this is the
movie before Charlie Cox was daredevil
then we know him in the big super star
of the Netflix Marvel adventure he was
he was the adorable awkward lead in this
just a really fun adventure film Claire
Danes a Michelle Pfeiffer and Mark
Strong and Robert De Niro is a
cross-dressing pirate in the boats in
the skies from Matthew Vaughn
oh maybe Wow Oh Daniel oh yeah Henry
Cavill is in it it's a fun eyeball pics
with good pics I'm an oddball but good
girl there you go my number four pick is
another cliche choice but it's a cliche
you might not hear millennial say it is
the movie that actually launched what
did we know as romantic comedies it's a
film called it happened one night have
you seen it no classic classic Clark
Gable and a girl it's a movie starring
Clark Gable and Claudette Colbert and I
just saw for the first time a couple
weeks ago my GF introduced me to this
film it surprisingly holds up really
well and I could see how it was like the
introduction of what a romantic comedy
is the guy and the girl they bicker with
each other they don't really get along
but you know they're into each other
like real-life really into this when I
watched this movie I was really taken
back by wow their chemistry on screen
for a 1934 film still is just as
powerful and more powerful than a lot of
romantic comedies that I see today
because it was the catalyst for what we
have is a romantic comedy genre it just
has to go on my list for what's check
out on Valentine's Day people that's the
movie that has the famous scene where
she lifts up her dress to stop the car
stops that payment that's always
parodied like insects in the city to the
movie yeah were they good like Saudi
Arabia yeah yeah that's what that's
always controversy loser number three
pics easy okay if you want to be with
your significant other on Valentine's
Day you're right or die your movie
partner for life the person you both
check in with on your movie packs you
want to have like a marathon yeah yeah
of course you want to be like a lazy
movie day marathon let's pig out being
loved on the couch you got a do a Lord
of the Rings trilogy marathon is that
what you shows yeah Lord of the Rings
Wow ball choice I just re-watched it to
today and I was like this is because
it's one of those movies where
especially if you've seen it a million
times you can kind of like talk during
it discuss scenarios and like well this
theory is that conspiracy blah blah like
it's a good movie to watch together and
it's long enough to where you can have
like an all-day thing I love how you're
breaking down the experience of being
with someone and watching it yeah yeah I
was thinking about my solo adventure and
ignoring my girlfriend why like yeah TV
and be like shut up baby I'm trying to
watch the movie your dear terrible
boyfriend it sounds like I'm an abusive
boyfriend there's a difference I still
love her that's how it works my number
three pick gosh I feel like I sort of
like be more creative with my listen die
hard with a vengeance is number three my
number three pick which I think might
appear on Stacy's list is When Harry Met
Sally
this was another film that I loved
because of how realistic it is and I
think that when I watched this film it's
probably the closest one in terms of
chemistry and dynamics and banter that I
have in my current relationship where
you don't really take anything too
seriously you can talk about whatever
you kind of have this best buddy best
friend relationship and I feel like for
the healthiest and the best couples
that's the kind of relationship you want
one where you could just bond and feel
like your best buds and then have you
know sex with each other yeah I wish I
could have sex with all my best friends
John
Jhansi what I'm really linking to and
it's funny the orgasm scene oh yeah yeah
my girlfriend does that all the time
yeah and in the bedroom she doesn't
never really doesn't yeah yeah I usually
I usually go to the other room and then
she's like alright now that we're done
I'm gonna go brush my teeth and she
makes all these moaning noises with her
electric toothbrush and I'm like man
with some crazy toothbrush she's doing
there hmm yeah she brushes her teeth
hard I guess I'm choosing brush called
the rabbit so we're gonna overlap with
that a bit so I'm gonna go to my number
one yeah number two's do an airy
mentality this is my number one I mean
we come from the comic book sci-fi
adventure fun movie world yeah I don't
have one of those sure a brand t-shirt
on me and my boyfriend's first
Valentine's Day together we of course
saw Deadpool together gosh you have
water food epilogue it was a Valentine's
it is a love story about a horrifying
looking man who constantly regenerates
and his girlfriend who I guess is cool
with this I don't know I don't know
where they're gonna do that relationship
like that kind of film you don't want to
sit there and watch you know I don't
know an affair to remember or whatever
these like romantic movies which I think
that one was actually really depressed
well then I just you want something you
can have fun with together so Deadpool
my number one choice
yeah what's what's your two and your one
my number two pick would have to be Blue
Valentine with Ryan Gosling and Michelle
Williams if you want to know what your
relationship is gonna turn into check
this movie out that's not really on my
number two of my choice would be Notting
Hill because that is just a fun movie
and that's another one that really
touches me a lot it's a really well made
there chemist Romani so good in that
movie like I actually didn't really love
Julia Roberts or love Hugh Grant until I
watched this movie one day I get why you
guys are the rom-com people did he grab
being charmingly befuddled and Julia
Roberts being quiet and I don't know
kind of his guy I hope you know that he
could hook up with a famous chick one
day and just be a regular dude yeah you
know Judi Dench Oh Marisa Tomei good
choice but she's a little too old for me
Marisa so make my number one pick would
be the most realistic one out of all my
cliche choices knocked up knocked up as
a film I love because I feel like in
real life most people I think have sex
with each other before they fall in love
the majority not everyone I'm not
talking about you Stacey
who waits till marriage Jesus I'm all
you guys to know I don't wait to over
that was the film that the first time I
saw it I actually didn't like it I
thought it was annoying then the second
time I watched it I thought it was a
very moving film I think that's a
perfect date movie to watch or a
favorite Valentine's Day movie to watch
because women can love that film because
it's a romantic film and guys will love
it too because it's got so much bro
humor and there's a camaraderie of guys
in there as well so I think that a lot
of times a Valentine's Day it's mainly
the girls holiday but if you're gonna
watch a movie together I think
knocked-up is that perfect film where a
guy and girl will both be heavily
satisfied by the end of it and also you
know it's a movie about people falling
in love with each other it's not about a
movie where they're a part and then they
decided like oh I love you and they say
in front of a big crowd at the end this
is a story about people who are in this
random situation a realistic one and
make it work in the end and then by the
end I'm like I'm really happy for these
guys and plus it's to mood that ruined
Katherine Heigl's career she made stupid
comment so you gotta watch I think I'm
not gonna bash it when I saw that that
was really funny I don't think it's
romantic anymore I think it's kind of
depressing because they were broken up
at one point in the movie nobody wants
to have a baby alone this is what I'm
saying
I know plenty of Mexican women in all
right pregnant this guy's here well I
guess we're doing this
I'm sure she'll grow to love him I think
you need to watch it she did love him by
the end
yeah that's the movie that everyone
loved it was a global box office it was
this guy she just shows I loved her
sisters relationship that was all
hilarious but in terms of like talking
about like oh it's a true romantic film
I didn't think it was romantic I thought
that's kind of depressing like and for
that part of it I'm not saying that they
couldn't have a happy relationship but
were they in the loves of each other's
life no well sometimes it's not about
soulmates well go get one don't take
your personal issues out on my choice
here movie night I do
well guys those are our top 5 movies to
watch on Valentine's Day I hope you'll
like Stacy's the first days of knocked
up for me thanks Stacy on my minds
easily influenced what are your top 5
favorite movies to watch on Valentine's
Day hopefully Stacy reads your choices
and bashes them subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell
false Stacy O'Halloran Instagram and
Twitter check out our patreon happy
[ __ ] Valentine's Day bye get out my
apartment stays ok